european ministers have called on
switzerland to honour its eu obligations
to respect the free movement of citizens
following a referendum in the country
over the weekend
the vote saw a slim majority of people
support immigration quotas
and while switzerland is not an eu
member it has signed agreements that
committed
not to hinder cross-border circulation
the council of the european union
respects the internal democratic
procedure of switzerland
and the outcome of the referendum
on the other hand the council expects
that the swiss federation confederation
will honor its obligation arising
from its agreements and treaties with
the european union
in other developments the general
affairs council could not reach a
qualified majority vote
against the introduction of a
genetically modified type of maze
under procedural arrangements the
decision now falls to the european
commission
the ministers also paved the way for a
summit of eu leaders in march
which will put the spotlight on climate
change energy and the economy
the leaders are set to debate a proposed
framework for energy for the 2020-2030
period
and to examine how much has been done to
implement energy recommendations they
handed down in may